[Música]
gracias por acompañarme en este espacio
dedicado al medio ambiente en france 24
a estas alturas todos sabemos que la
emisión de co2 derivada de la quema de
combustibles fósiles como la gasolina el
carbón o el gas natural es nociva para
el planeta y para el futuro del ser
humano la ciencia ha demostrado una y
otra vez que la clave está en reducir
las emisiones sin embargo la ciencia
también tiene claro que la reducción de
estas no será suficiente para lograr
mantener el termómetro a un nivel
adecuado para que los humanos podamos
vivir decentemente hay tanto dióxido de
carbono acumulado en la atmósfera que la
solución además de dejar de emitir lo
requiere que quitemos algunos de estos
contaminantes ya existentes para poder
llegar a un nivel de neutralidad de
emisiones para lograr esto existe una
técnica llamada captura directa de
dióxido de carbono y hace unos días en
islandia se inauguró la planta más
grande del mundo que además es la
primera que almacena co2 de manera
permanente hablé con la directora de
mercadeo the climb works juli gosálbez
quien nos explicó cómo funciona este
proceso
lo que hace que se llama captura directa
de aire esto quiere decir que se pintó
el aire del ambiente para extraer el co2
o dióxido de carbono
una vez se filtra a través de estos
grandes ventiladores que se dan en las
imágenes de la planta el co2 es
capturado
una vez es capturado pueden pasar dos
cosas se recicla o se almacena en el
caso de oro aunque es la primera y mayor
planta de captura directa y de
almacenamiento de aire en el mundo se
guarda bajo tierra a través de un
proceso de mineralización operado por
nuestro aliado karpin
así que una vez el seudo se captura lo
mandamos a car fix y ellos lo mezclan
con agua lo bombean bajo tierra y ahí se
liberaliza en roca basáltica
la roca basáltica es de las más comunes
en la tierra tiene unos pequeños
agujeros y una vez que el agua es
bombeada y llena a estos huecos el co2
se mineraliza y se convierte en berga
así que el co2 se convierte en roca y se
queda atrapado en la piedra ya existente
y existe visto la planta bautizada por
cal que en irlandés significa energía
utiliza energía geotérmica para su
funcionamiento así que el impacto en
cuanto a emisiones es casi nulo de hecho
desde su construcción hasta el final de
su vida útil orca sólo se emite el 10
por ciento de las emisiones que almacena
por ahora esta planta es capaz de
capturar y almacenar de manera
permanente 4000 toneladas de dióxido de
carbono al año una cantidad pequeña
teniendo en cuenta que en 2019 emitimos
más de 33 mil millones de toneladas y en
2020 por los efectos de la pandemia unos
31.500 millones así que harían falta
unos 8 millones 350 mil sistemas como
gorka para remover todo el co2 que
emitimos cada año además los costos son
muy altos quitar una tonelada de co2 del
aire cuesta 1.100 dólares sin embargo en
claymont son optimistas en cuanto a su
crecimiento y con él el abaratamiento de
capturar el co2
en cuanto a la expansión hemos
multiplicado en nuestra capacidad por 10
en los últimos 23 años continuaremos con
este ritmo en los próximos 12 3 y
después de eso probablemente creceremos
a un ritmo de entre 5 y 10 veces lo que
son ritmos parecidos a la industria
eólica en los últimos 30 a 40 años la
experiencia ha demostrado que los costos
se han reducido drásticamente alrededor
de unas 25 veces para la industria
eólica así que seguramente sea mucho
menor para la captura directa de aire lo
que la hace muy viable y eso nos da
mucha confianza de que nos sucederá lo
mismo y nos dirijamos hacia lo que
necesita el mercado según los fundadores
the climb works este sistema es mil
veces más eficiente capturando carbono
que los árboles y esperan poder alcanzar
el millón de toneladas capturadas al año
en la segunda mitad de esta década
otra manera de controlar las emisiones
del planeta es a través de la
conservación de bosques y selvas y este
es uno de los objetivos de terramar el
proyecto financiado por la agencia
francesa de desarrollo en cuatro países
sudamericanos brasil colombia ecuador y
perú hace unos meses les hablábamos del
lanzamiento del proyecto en colombia y
ahora nuestro corresponsal en perú
francisco zacarías nos muestra parte de
lo que será el proyecto en la amazonía
peruana
víctor zambrano ha vivido a la mitad de
su vida cuidando los bosques y denuncia
que su región sufre la más alta
deforestación de los últimos 20 años
estamos hablando de un promedio de un
área totalmente deforestada de 25.000
hectáreas
sobre una superficie que está bajo
impacto de más de 100 mil hectáreas
prácticamente
los guardabosques alertan que mi madre
de dios la naturaleza agoniza en esta
región ubicada al oriente del perú la
minería y la tala ilegal destruyen la
biodiversidad
atendiendo esta emergencia ambiental la
agencia francesa de desarrollo lanzó el
proyecto de ramas que busca detener la
deforestación y mejorar la vida de sus
habitantes vamos a trabajar con nuestros
socios del proyecto aquí en perú pero
también sobre los otros sitios sobre
tres ejes diferentes el primer eje es un
eje de creación de la marca territorial
por ejemplo aquí en madrid es el segundo
eje es un eje de apoyo científico y de
capacitación para los socios del
proyecto y porcino
crear una apoyar iniciativas
mientras
con las poblaciones locales para
desarrollar carreras de valor
sostenibles
madre de dios produce el cacao y
diversos productos naturales miles de
indígenas tienen la esperanza de que te
ramas genere más empleo y también les
ayude a ampliar sus ventas en europa con
los productos salir más allá no
solamente quedarnos con rusia no de
repente a otros países más más grandes
en potencial del consumo de productos
orgánicos a sus casi 75 años víctor
zambrano anhela que cuando ella no viva
los peruanos hayan aprendido a valorar
la biodiversidad y ya no se necesite a
los guardabosques sólo la naturaleza y
el tiempo lo dirán
con este tema me despido hasta las
semanas
[Música]